i
[Música]
se cumple un año desde que joe biden
asumió la presidencia estadounidense el
mandatario reconoció errores en su
gestión al tiempo que el senado rechazó
su proyecto de reforma electoral que
buscaba ampliar y proteger el derecho al
voto tenemos análisis
y este aniversario llega en medio de las
tensiones con rusia por las que el
secretario de estado de eeuu está de
gira por europa
hoy desde alemania abogó por una salida
pacífica no obstante señaló que habrá un
alto costo para moscú si ataca a ucrania
ampliamos desde berlín
un nuevo escándalo rodea al primer
ministro británico boris johnson un
diputado conservador acusó al gobierno
de chantajear a los parlamentarios que
se oponen al premier johnson aseguró que
no hay pruebas
buenas tardes para todos bienvenidos a
esta emisión de noticias en france 24
soy valentina torre sánchez iniciamos en
estados unidos joe biden cumple un año
en la casa blanca en medio del auge en
los casos de kobe 19 por la variante
omicron la mayor inflación en décadas y
reveses importantes para su gestión
según sondeos el mandatario pasó de
tener una aprobación del 56 por ciento
en enero de 2021 al 42 por ciento en
enero de 2022 pese a victorias como la
aprobación de su plan de alivio por el
commit 19 de 1,9 billones de dólares y
su paquete de infraestructura por más de
un billón de dólares
para analizar este periodo conectamos
con los genes combinar analista político
y consultor internacional
bienvenido a france 24 ha habido varios
reveses para el mandatario el más
reciente fue que el senado hundió su
plan de reforma al sistema electoral y
hay otros factores como la retirada de
afganistán que son muy cuestionados esta
baja en la favorabilidad le puede jugar
en contra y hacer que pierda el control
de las cámaras que los demócratas
pierdan el control de las cámaras en las
elecciones de medio término
sí bueno buenas tardes definitivamente
con ese bajo popularidad y con los
reversos que ha sucedido con el señor
baile el control de los demócratas de la
cámara de representantes está en peligro
normalmente el partido que está en poder
va a perder escaños en las elecciones se
llaman meterme y en este año es casi
seguro que los republicanos van a tomar
control de la cámara de representantes
la cuestión es que si los demócratas
pueden mantener control sobre el senado
si pueden mantener ese lado tienen mayor
chance de avanzar con uno de los
proyectos del país si pierden ambos
casas va a ser muy difícil para el
presidente cuáles son los principales
retos que le esperan al jefe de estado
para 2022
definitivamente el primero es la
economía y la inflación el pueblo
americano ve todos los días en los
supermercados en las estaciones de
gasolina y en el alquiler de las casas
un aumento y eso siempre va a causar
problemas para un mandatario él tiene
que tomar control sobre eso empezando
aflojando las cadenas de suministro que
están restringiendo mucho la economía y
causando la situación también el
resurgimiento de comida de un pacto
grande él tiene que ir tomar control
sobre eso y con empezando a bajar las
sentencias y los contagios de omicron
hay señales que él puede hacer eso
finalmente yo bailé fue elegido porque
él dijo que puede hacer cosas que tenía
una historia en el senado de los eeuu
que muestra que él es capaz de manejar
el gobierno y lograr objetivos él ha
tenido unos drivers as muy dramáticas y
muy públicas en el congreso él tiene que
volver
a tener proyectos prácticos que pueden
recibir el apoyo de ambas cámaras en el
congreso y así ser puede tener unos
logros aunque no tan grandes y masivos
como él quería
unos logros prácticos y mostrar que él
sí tiene control sobre la situación
señor gran bien era usted muchas gracias
por su análisis y por compartirlo con
nosotros en france24 y en berlín el
secretario de estado de eeuu anthony
blinken se reunió con el secretario
general de la otan jens stoltenberg y el
jefe de la diplomacia europea joseph
murray esta escala en berlin es la
última antes de que mañana viernes
blinken se reúna con su contraparte rusa
el canciller sérguei lávrov conectamos
con tomás sparrow él es corresponsal de
france 24 en la capital alemana thomas
que otras conclusiones o qué
conclusiones se conocen tras el
encuentro de los líderes
la principal conclusión es el enfoque
diplomático quieren por supuesto
discutir posibles soluciones con rusia
le han pedido a rusia y es algo que
también va a reiterar blinken en su
reunión con sergei lávrov que rusia tome
medidas para de escalar la situación de
lo contrario si rusia hace lo que se
pueda describir como una agresión los
aliados de eeuu y en particular también
alemania pero otros aliados han
asegurado que habrá consecuencias para
rusia por supuesto lo que se estuvo
discutiendo hoy aquí en berlín entre los
principales países que se reunieron eeuu
francia alemania y reino unido- es qué
tipo de consecuencias podría haber si en
efecto rusia hace lo que se considere
una agresión bueno y después de estas
declaraciones que se espera puntualmente
de la reunión entre blinken y lávrov
mañana en ginebra
blinken dijo y precisamente aquí en
berlín que no espera que mañana la
situación se solucione del todo son
pasos que se van a dar hacia una posible
solución el principal objetivo del
secretario de estado será presentar la
postura de eeuu a lo que por supuesto
hizo hoy también aquí en la capital
alemana y presentar también la posición
de los otros aliados de eeuu
precisamente ese enfoque en la
diplomacia algo particularmente
importante para alemania alemania ha
reiterado que quiere tener un enfoque
diplomático muy claro por ejemplo
reactivando lo que se llama el formato
de normandía junto a francia para
negociar con ucrania y con rusia es algo
que también se va a discutir mañana en
ginebra pero falta ver qué tanta
disponibilidad y que tanto interés
también hay de parte de rusia así que
por un lado está todo el tema
diplomático por el otro lado también
está la posibilidad de sanciones o de
consecuencias si el tema se agrava en la
frontera con ucrania tomás gracias por
esta ampliación estamos muy pendientes
de lo que ocurre en las próximas horas y
la tormenta que rodea al primer ministro
británico boris johnson no se sabe este
jueves un diputado conservador al
gobierno de chantajear a aquellos
parlamentarios que planean presentar una
carta con miras a activar la moción de
confianza por la gestión del premier
johnson digo que haya pruebas y
suficientes apoyos podrían provocar su
destitución tras los escándalos el más
reciente las fiestas en la residencia
oficial del gobierno alva santana no se
amplia
los problemas en torno a boris johnson
parecen no terminar en medio de la
lluvia de críticas en su contra por
asistir a una fiesta en downing street
en pleno confinamiento ahora un
legislador conservador acusa a su
gobierno por chantaje
en los últimos días varios diputados se
han enfrentado a presiones e
intimidaciones por parte de miembros del
gobierno tras suponer o expresar su
deseo de presentar un voto de confianza
contra el primer ministro y la
intimidación de un miembro del
parlamento es un asunto grave y es que
desde que se filtró la asistencia de
johnson a la fiesta son muchos los
diputados de su propio partido los que
le han dado la espalda presentando
cartas de confianza en su contra que
podrían llegar a destituirlo si se
prueban estas amenazas o intentos de
coacción pasaría a ser asunto de la
justicia acusaciones que johnson niega
he visto evidencia se ha sabido nada
sobre ninguna de esas alegaciones sobre
todo porque estoy centrado en qué
hacemos con el problema número uno de
los británicos que es el cómic 19 coming
hasta ahora johnson se niega a dimitir
tras los escándalos asegurando que
llevara a su partido a las próximas
elecciones previstas para 2024 el primer
ministro ganó los comicios de 2019 con
un amplio respaldo no obstante estas
filtraciones amenazan con hundir su
popularidad en reino unido el papa
emérito benedicto 16 fue acusado de
inacción en cuatro casos de pedofilia en
alemania cuando él era un alto
funcionario del vaticano pese a que el
periódico alemán die zeit denunció
reportes entregados a joseph ratzinger
sobre el tema el pontífice de mérito en
retiro negó haber recibido información
sobre lo sucedido dos de los casos que
se remontan a la época en la que
ratzinger era aps arzobispo de munich
involucran a clérigos señalados de abuso
que permanecieron activos
y este jueves se llevó a cabo en la
segunda jornada de movilizaciones de
profesores en francia en contra de lo
que han calificado como políticas
erráticas del gobierno frente al coi 19
los profesores denuncian que los
lineamientos en materia educativa están
siendo modificados constantemente y no
protegen ni al profesorado ni a los
estudiantes adecuadamente asimismo
condenaron al ministro michel blanquea
luego de que se conociera que el
protocolo para el regreso a clases fue
anunciado desde ibiza donde el
funcionario estaba pasando vacaciones
llegamos al final del informativo pero
volveremos en breve con más aquí en
france 24
[Música]